[Music]
haha well hello there reject nation
I'm Greg Alba and I'm John Humphrey we
are going to do a try not to laugh
Tyrone Magnus edition my cuts to the
Tyrone impersonation you have a deeper
voice than I did one of our top reward
tiers on patreon or the top is whatever
video you're requesting was doing put on
YouTube
today comes from a man named gene Jeter
and we've reacted a several of his short
films and such and a couple of his
monologues from his own personal channel
and he has done a surprising video here
this is a few years old is room 27 2015
let's see if this is still good don't
laugh John if you will laugh try so hard
Magnus
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
both work with one out box a head of
hair he has gone full rocket
my favorite my god
should be it tries to get scared
challenge no just doing cocaine you made
me laugh though this is how chocolate
this is exactly how this would be an
insert in the middle of a conversation
whatever video it's from job exactly
this long-term probably just I was scary
[Music]
ah
old-school Tyrone I think my favorite
one is just that ah the first one that
popped in at random where he's in the
sweater and it's all up close man that
was magical Jean that's I was honestly
is I thought we were just walking into a
typical try to laugh like God jeans
probably composed what he considers the
funniest bits from Tyrone Magnus and
we're just gonna watch a compilation and
I'm like I'm down for that
Tyrone's my homie I [ __ ] love him and
I thought this would be like yeah yeah
I've seen this video
yeah yeah I've seen that's a great
that's a great time and then we got into
you you guys got a collab this is like I
got to poop boggle you guys I would do
is I would this yes exactly how I would
want to kind of try not to laugh
challenge because I think well it's
actually really edited and I love the
weirdness and Johnny do you take the
talk away oh no I mean this is all you
know because you said like that there is
a point where it crosses over and it
being kind of creepy and scary and
disturbing and I think that in a way you
have tapped into the magical thread that
separates you know horror and comedy
because these are funny moments and
they're naturally amusing things Tyrone
does it still would be effective if you
just put it as a linear try not to laugh
challenge and yet somehow I think it's
even funnier and more engrossing because
of how weird and like calculated it all
like because it's like glitchy and it's
supposed to just be like what is
happening right now yeah you know you
have a fair amount of freedom just to
kind of mess with it however you want to
but especially because it doesn't
outstay its welcome to much you get just
to the point where you're like I have no
idea where this is gonna go or how it's
gonna end I just know it's gonna be a
lot of Tyrone you know and in that way
this was the most effective try not to
laugh challenge of F's yeah is usually a
lot of times I can bring my mind to
apply
so I'm like I can zone out and I just
could not at all yeah that was a
freaking trippy I mean what's funny is
is like from seeing Jean short films
you're like oh yeah he definitely edited
this but did see it done in such comedic
fashion I thought was great like if you
can infuse this kind of crazy style for
because you kind of make these sort of
cerebral extraterrestrials esoteric kind
of short films that are really deep
meanings but I mean we're a fantasy all
I bet you were thrilled that we love
this if you see our sketches especially
the ones that are not like riffing on
like a let's just pull this scene out of
a movie and like redo it or low five
fashion but yeah we like to eventually
transition into like some type of weird
horror territory and or something serene
so this was like our kind of comedy
right here yeah this is really funny and
weird and really edited but then to go
like oh this is actually kind of scary
now and look creepy and you're never not
trying my evil laugh I really
appreciated this as I thought we were
just going into another you know cliched
try not to laugh challenge just you know
whatever you personally thought was
funny yeah this like you made funny
because of how [ __ ] like I love that you
just use it ever was at your iMovie
disposal or something yeah what could I
do here what can I do here I'm like that
it's so fun and like the way you remixed
it will you loop things - will you loop
things - will you Louie Louie you loop
things - I thought was hilariously
edited this is this is this is great
this is one of the best trends - laughs
I've ever seen like this is just an
entertaining video yeah plus you know
now Tyrone Magnus is you know as a
horror icon so thank you for that and I
want to say man I like you know I'm
Tyron for quite a few years I don't know
what 20 years so obviously after the
force awakens came out something like
that right or the gym the trailer for
force awakens came out sometime around
that I missed this background I did
because it always will allowed him to
have this space Toto move here but with
Tyrone's shot here I've always loved it
because he could walk up and he wouldn't
lose frame yeah you know he doesn't have
he doesn't have to duck to get in fair
like I always thought this frame was
perfect and it just feels so personal
you know his studio apartment in New
Jersey he's done so well he's got a
house now and everything I like his
background now I just miss this layer
and there's center area - yeah it's got
full dwayne johnson now it's like any
really you can look back on the old
seasons and be like mom just look how
far we've got this is from 2015 so i'm
like yeah this is like the old days
where all it was about like more
reactions felt more like vlogs yeah he
still has that vibe as you know still
watch his videos great far from home
reaction he had to learn hey home go
check out gene channel man dude the
guy's an inventive dude obviously gene
joints he's an artist he's a novelist
sir agra fur photographs some beautiful
beautiful children drop a like on this
video thanks G this is great this is a
great time plenty of alcohol require you
guys can subscribe to the reject nation
click that notification bell and chicky
has a leader